شددت اثيوبيا على رفضها لما سمته محاولات
مصر تدويل ملف سد النهضه قائله ان مياه
ميل يجب ان تبقى ملفا افقيا وفيما كادت
اديس ابابا ان عمليات تعبئه السد لم تلحق
اي ضرر بدولتي المصب مصر والسودان حضرت
القاهره مما وصفته بتحركه اثيوبيا
الاحاديه معتبره اياها خرقا للقانون
الدولي يهدد حياه عشرات ملايين الناس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي تحركات المصريه
الاخيره التي دفعت اثيوبيا للاعلام مجددا
عن رفضها ما سمته محاولات القاهره تدويل
ملف سد النهضه ومن هي الاطراف الدوليه
المعنيه للازمه وما حجم تاثير عمليات
تعبئه السده الثلاثه السابقه على دول
المصب واحواض الانهار المشتركه من النواحي
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والبيئيه وهل تشكل
عمليه الملء وتشغيل سد النهضه خطرا وجوديا
وكارثيا على نحو 150 مليون شخص كما ذكر
وزير الري المصري وما هي فرص الوصول الى
حلول وتفاهمات مشتركه بين اطراف النزاع
والحيلوله دون تصاعد الازمه
[موسيقى]
بقيه ومستمره هي الهوه العميقه في الخلاف
الدائري بين مصر واثيوبيا بشان مساري
تشغيل سد النهضه فكلما بلغ ذلك المسار
محطه جديده من تعبئه خزان المياه نشطت
المواقف والمواقف المضاده من هذا الطرف او
ذاك الخلافات لا تتوقف عند التفاصيل
التقنيه والتي تقول مصر ان انعكاساتها
ستكون
كارثيه على شعوب دولتي المصب بل تتجاوز
ذلك الى الاطار الذي يريد كل طرف وضع
الازمه ضمنه فبينما تحرص اديس ابابا على
ان ينفرد الاتحاد الافريقي بالوساطه بين
اطراف الخلاف ترى مصر ان عمق المشكله
يستدعي اطارا اماميا ودوليا اوسع لتطويقها
وحلها قبل فوات الاوان المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الاثيوبيه على
ان ملف مياه النيل يجب ان يبقى شانا
افريقيا على حد تعبيره
لديهم رغبه لتدوين ملف سد النهضه وترسيخ
صورتي ان اثيوبيا لا تحترم القوانين
الدوليه هذا ما ينشر في وسائل الاعلام
المصريه هي محاولات لتحويل ملف سد النهضه
الى ملف دولي ونحن نرفض هذا الامر مياه
النيل افريقيه تخص دولها وملفه سد النهضه
يرعاه الاتحاد الافريقي وتدخل الجامعه
العربيه كان خاطئا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره السفير حسين هريدي مساعد وزير
الخارجيه المصريه السابق ومن اديس ابا
محمد العروسي النائب في البرلمان
الفيدراليه الاثيوبي اهلا بكما في هذه
الحلقه وابدا معك الاستاذ العروسي في اديس
ابا يعني من خلال المواقف الصادره ما يقول
انه القضيه او الازمه ما زالت تراوح
مكانها لكن هناك اجراءات على الارض
الاجراءات الاثيوبيه بتقدم اسد نحو
اكتمالها اليس كذلك
اولا شكرا على الاستضافه والتحيه لك
ولضيفك الكريم سعاده السفير والساده
المشاهدين كل عام وانتم بخير مجددا نعم هو
الامر كذلك بالضبط يعني حينما ننظر الى ان
هناك اوقات موسميه يتطلب الوقت من اثيوبيا
في هذا الموسم ان تجري هذه الانشاءات وهذه
الاكمالات لهذه الانشاءات في هذه الفترات
الموسميه والتي توافقوا عليها حسب هذه
اللجنه المشكله من الدول الثلاثه اكثر
يعني من من 15 عالم تقريبا هذه اللجنه
توافقت على ان يكون هناك ميعاد لكل امر
يعني هناك امور موسميه كلها قضايا فنيه
بامتياز فبالتالي نحن هذه الاجراءات
نتخذها على الارض ضمانا للمصداقيه
الاثيوبيه
وايضاحا للعالم بان الاجراءات الاثيوبيه
انما جاءت بالخير وبالسلام وكذلك اثبتت
مصداقيه ما كانت تردده اثيوبيا على مدار
الاثني عشر عاما هي كانت تزعم ولا زالت
تؤكد بان سد النهضه انما هو مصدر حياه
للاشقاء في مصر والسودان وكل من اراد
الاستفاده منه ونحن لا نختلف عن الاطلاق
ولا نمانع ان تقوم القاهره بتقديم اي من
المخاوف المنطقيه انما نمانع ونرفض هذه
المبالغه في توصيف قضيه سد النهضه للعالم
ليس سد النهضه مصدر الاذى والخراب والدمار
كما يزعمون ويصورون للعالم وان كان هناك
حديث عن استهداف السد ان كان هناك حديث عن
الاضرار بالسد والاعتداء على الامن القومي
الاثيوبي الذي من الذي اصدرها
على هذا الكلام
هل هناك
نيه في الاعتداء على السد كما تقول لديك
اثباتات انا اتحدث انا اتحدث انا اتحدث عن
من انا لم ازعم ان هناك من زعم ذلك لكن
اقول الزعم بهذا الامر خطير سواء التلميح
او التصريح بهذا الامر نحن نرفضه قطعا
لذلك كالخيارات المفتوحه وغيرها نعم وما
قولك في الخيارات المفتوحه والمغلقه ماذا
نتحدث عن هذه الخيارات التي ننتقدمونها
نعم وكذلك مدلوقه ونحن بها ننتقل الى
السفير حسين هويدي في الهريدي عفوا في
القاهره يقول استمعت الى الاستاذ محمد
العروسي هي مجرد ما تقوم به اثيوبيا مجرد
قضايا اجرائيه فنيه موسميه ولا تقصد ابدا
من ورائها الاضرار باي طرف من الاطراف لا
بمصر ولا بالسودان استمعت اليه هل هذا
الكلام مطمئن بالنسبه لكم في مصر
يعني بدايه شكرا على الاستضافه وتحياتي
لحضرتك وللمشاهدين الكريم في اديس ابابا
عاصمه الاتحاد الافريقي الذي يجمع كل
الدول الافريقيه
حضرتك من حيث المبدا اسمحي لي في البدايه
ان انا اؤكد على حقيقه بالنسبه للموقف
المصري من موضوع
سد النهضه
عندما تصدر تصريحات في مصر عن ضروره
التوصل الى اتفاق
حول
سد النهضه ده لا يعني ابدا ان احنا عارضنا
او نعارض في استكمال بناء سد النهضه
القضيه من وجهه نظر مصريه مش في السد
النهضه بل بالعكس اعتقد اعتبارا من 2014
وحتى اليوم
تصريحات المسؤولين وعلى اعلى مستوى في
الدوله المصريه ان مصر لا تعارض انشاء سد
النهضه او استكمال بناءه وانما مصر بتطلب
وتناشد الحكومه الاثيوبيه
بالجلوس مجددا على مائده المفاوضات للتوصل
الى اتفاق حول اداره سد النهضه
وخصوصا في موسم الجفاف والجفاف الممتد طيب
او النقطه تاني نقطه
احنا بمصر في انتظار ان الحكومه الاثيوبيه
تعلن عن استعدادها للتوصل الى مثل هذا
الاتفاق الى هذه اللحظه لم يصدر عن اي
مسؤول اثيوبي ان اثيوبيا ستتقدم بمشروع
اتفاق يلبي المصالح المشروعه للاطراف
التلاته النقطه النقطه الاخرى حضرتك انه
القول بانه نهر النيل وسد النهضه ده ملف
يجب ان يتم
تعاطي معه في الاطار الافريقي فطبعا احنا
مصر مؤيده لذلك يعني خلال الاربع سنوات
الماضيه خلال رئاسه جنوب افريقيا للاتحاد
الافريقي ثم رئاسه دوله الكونغو
الديمقراطيه ثم رئاسه السنغال ثم الرئاسه
الحاليه للاتحاد الافريقي جزر القمر ومصر
تطالب مصر لا تعارض ابدا الحل الافريقي
وعندما مصر مصر لا تسعى للتدوين احنا لا
ندوله القضيه اساسا قضيه دوليه اذا لماذا
تسعى لماذا تصر مصر على الذهاب الى
الجامعه العربيه والذهاب الى الامم
المتحده وادخال اطراف دوليه في هذه القضيه
الجميع الجامعه العربيه حضرتك لا ننسى
ونحن نتحدث عن الجامعه العربيه ان الجامعه
العربيه بتضم ست دول تقع في افريقيا ست
دول في شمال افريقيا فالجامعه العربيه
جامعه عربيه وجمع افريقيه في ذات الوقت
القمه الاخيره الدوليه التي في الجزائر
يعني موضوع سد النهضه لم يكن مطروحا البته
في جدول اعمال القمه كيف تفسر ذلك اذا
مش مشيت قضيه يا فندم يعني مش دي قضيه
احنا دلوقتي اذا كانت اثيوبيا مستعده
للتوصل اتفاق الاتحاد الافريقي موجود
رئاسه الاتحاد الافريقي موجوده في في
حضرتك اتفاقيات دوليه
للمشاركه في الانهار الدوليه في ثلاث
معاهدات دوليه حضرتك ممكن الارتكان اليها
المعاهده الاولى اللي هي معاهده حضرتك
تقاسم مياه نهر الاندوس بين الهند
وباكستان تلك المعاهده الدوليه التي تم
التوصل اليها في عام 1963 ثم هناك معاهده
افريقيه
لتقاسم نهر السنغال ثم هناك معاهده اخرى
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكندا
تعرف باسم معاهده حوض نهر كولومبيا
ودي معاهده يعني بتنظم امور شبيهه شبيهه
بالامور المرتبطه بسد الن موضوع توليد
الكهرباء وموضوع الفيضانات عندما تحدث كيف
يمكن ان يعمل تعمل السدود على نهر
كولومبيا ففي ثلاث معاهدات دوليه يمكن كان
اليها في التوصل الى اتفاق بين مصر
واثيوبيا والسودان حول حول اداره وتشغيل
مش حوالين سد النهضه طيب في حد السؤال على
محمد العروسي هناك مرجعيه ذكرها الان
السفير حسين هريدي لماذا لا يعني لا يعود
او تعود الاطراف هذه الى هذه المرجعيات
الثلاث التي تحدث عنها الاستاذ هريدي الان
لحلله هذا الموضوع بشكل يرضي كل الاطراف
اولا لان الاشقاء يجلسون في واشنطن ثم
ينادون على اثيوبيا من هناك ان اجلسوا الى
مفاوضات نحن نجلسها في واشنطن وفي غيرها
بينما نحن توافقنا على ان تكون على ان
تكون المنظومه الافريقيه هي المقر
والحاضنه والراعيه لهذه المفاوضات هذا امر
الامر الاخر يتحدث سعاده السفير عن موقف
الجامعه العربيه وانها يعني يعني دوله او
كيان يجب ان يتدخل بحكم كونه عربيا
وافريقيا هذا امر غير صحيح نحن لا نتحدث
عن مجامله معينه يا سعاده السفير نحن
نتحدث عن واقع الجامعه العربيه تربطنا لها
بعثه في اديس ابابا تربطنا علاقات جيده
بسعاده السفراء العرب لكن في نفس الوقت
الجامعه العربيه ليست جزءا من هذه الازمه
فليست هي بسودانيه وليست هي بمصريه ولا
اثيوبيه حتما ومع ذلك تم طرح مقابله
تلفزيونيه في احدى المرات قريبا يعني
للامين العام لجامعه الدول
عندما سالوه قالوا له لماذا لا تتخذون
يعني كوسيط دورا تلعبونه كوسيط في هذه
الازمه قال نحن اتخذنا الموقف بانحيازنا
الى مصر فاين هذا الامر الذي نوده ان
نطرحه حتى على الجامع العربي
ايضا تلام عليه اثيوبيا بالنسبه للاتحاد
الافريقي واصرار اثيوبيا على فقط الاتحاد
الافريقي يعني يعكس ايضا نفوضا اثيوبيا
داخل الاتحاد الافريقي الموجود في مقره في
اديس ابابا
يا استاذه خديجه نحن نتحدث عن ما توافقنا
عليه في مفاوضات ابرمتها الدول هناك
اتفاقيه تسمى باتفاقيه اعلان المبادئ او
الاطاريه في 2015 هذه الاتفاقيه وفي بندها
العاشر تنص على ان يعني الخلافات تحل عن
طريق التوافق واذا لزم الامر يعني يكون
الامر حتى التدوين عبر التوافق مع الدول
المعنيه عبر التوافق بين الدول المعنيه
مصر والسودان واثيوبيا وهكذا يجري التدوين
فان تفرض الاجنده وتطالب اثيوبيا بان
تلتزم باجنده ابرمتها انت مع غير اثيوبيا
هذا امر لا يقبله المنطق نحن نحافظ على
سيادتنا وما جلسنا في هذه المفاوضات على
مدار عقد من الزمان الا للوصول الى حل
يتساءل سعاده السفير يقول اين المسؤول
الذي يرفض او يطالب بالوصول الى حل مشترك
حل يرضي الاطراف الثلاثه ابتداء من فخامه
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي حتى اصغر مسؤول صرح
عن هذه القضيه كلهم دعوا الى رغبه اثيوبيا
في الوصول الى حل شامل يا سعاده السفير
انا اتحدث وانا مسؤول اثيوبي ايضا اقول
نحن ندعو الى الوصول الى حل يرضي جميع
الاطراف على ان لا يكون ثمنه السياده
الاثيوبيه او الحقوق الاثيوبيه او الحصص
التاريخيه التي تزعمون بانها حق لكم من
اين قسمتم هذه الحصص ومن اين يعني يعني
والحقوق والحصص متعلقه بالسودان والحصص
انما يقررها اصحابها اصحابها دول حوض
النيل هي من تقدم
ولا يصح ان تقوم
السيد محمد العروسي من انه في النهايه هذه
اتفاقيه بين دول
وهناك اعلان مبادئ وقعت سنه 2015 هناك
تطمنات اثيوبيه رسميه على لسان اعلى مسؤول
في الدوله الاثيوبيه بانه لن يكون هناك
اضرار بمصالح مصر والسودان الا يشكل هذا
اساس ربما لاي مفاوضات بين مصر واثيوبيا
في هذا الموضوع
يعني طبعا
نرحب حضرتك باي تصريحات ايجابيه تصدر عن
الحكومه الاثيوبيه او عن البرلمان
الاثيوبي اللي بيمثل الشعب الاثيوبي
بالنسبه لهذه القضيه السؤال المطروح هنا
طيب اذا كانت كل هذه النوايا الطيبه ونحن
لا نشكك في هذه النوايا الطيبه طب لماذا
لا يتم ترجمتها الى اتفاق بين الدول
الثلاثه يعني مساله احنا لا نشكك في
النوايا الطيبه للحكومه الاثيوبيه
والاعضاء البرلمان الاثيوبي اللي هم
ليس لديهم اي نيه للاضرار بمصالح مصر في
مياه نهر النيل اهلا وسهلا طب ما نترجم
دوت في اتفاق يعني يحفظ
الحقوق والمصالح مصر والسودان واثيوبيا دي
اول نقطه ثاني نقطه
الاتفاق حول اداره
سد النهضه لا يمس السياده الاثيوبيه من
قريب او من بعيد وانا هحيل حضراتكم
ولضيفكم الكريم
ممثلا لمجلس للبرلمان الاثيوبي الى القمه
الامريكيه الكنديه الاخيره في كندا والتي
جمعت بين الرئيس جو بايدن والرئيس الوزراء
الكندي تريدوه وحدثهم وحديثهم وتناولهم
لموضوع
معاهده حوض نهر
كولومبيا
فيعني يعني الكلام اللي اتقال انه يعني
ممكن يبنى عليه وممكن يكون مرجع في لدى
الحكومه الاثيوبيه ان هي تقدم
مشروع اتفاق
للحكومتين المصريه
والسودانيه اذا رجعنا للتصريحات التي تم
الادلاء بها وما تم الاتفاق عليه بين
الجانبين الامريكي والكندي نجد
اتفاق نموذجي يحتذى به في جميع القضايا
المتعلقه بتقاسم والمشاركه في الانهار
الدوليه يعني اننا
انا ارجو مش استنساخ بالحرف حضرتك يعني
ممكن جدا تبقى هي مرجعيه قانونيه
لطرح مشروع لصياغه مشروع اتفاق يلبي مصالح
وحقوق الدول الثلاثه اثيوبيا ومصر
والسودان
القضيه بالنسبه لمصر احنا لسنا في خصومه
مع اثيوبيا احنا عايزين حضرتك نتطلع ونربط
ولكن
الخارجيه
يعني انت هذا الخطاب التصالحي
لا يعكسه كلام وزير الخارجيه سامح شكري
عندما قال انه كل الخيارات مفتوحه للتعامل
في التعامل مع اثيوبيا بما يوحي بانه هناك
خيار عسكري يمكن ان تلجا اليه مصر
ممكن ممكن ممكن اعلق على هذا تفضل ممكن
اعلق على هذا اتفضل نعم
الحكايه الخيارات مفتوحه
الاشاره اولا بالنسبه لمصر حضرتك مصر من
البدايه وحتى هذه اللحظه
بتؤكد على التزامها بالدبلوماسيه
اول شيء تاني شيء حضرتك تفسيري لتصريح
وزير الخارجيه المصري اللي حضرتك تكرمتي
واشرتي اليه عندما قال كل البدائل مفتوحه
هو يقصد البدائل المنصوص عليها في ميثاق
الامم المتحده اي ان ممكن الوساطه ممكن
المساعي الحميده ممكن التوفيق ممكن
المفاوضات كل هذا حضرتك يعني اذا رجعتي
حضرتك لميثاق الامم المتحده والفصل السادس
في الميثاق اللي هو بيتعلق بتسويه
المنازعات بين الدول بالطرق السلميه هتجد
حضرتك ان هو نص على هذه البدائل فانا انا
تفسيري لتصريح وزير الخارجيه المصري هو
انه دي البدائل المتاحه امام مصر دي
البدائل المتاحه امام مصر اما الاشاره او
اما الايحاء بان مصر بتفكر في عمل عسكري
وراها ما هترفع السلاح في وجه اي عربي او
اي مش مطروح شكرا طيب محمد عروسي
الكلام الذي سمعنا اليه بخصوص كندا
وامريكا ليكون ربما كمرجعيه لما لا في فض
المنازعات او النزاعات حول
ازمات المياه هل يمكن ان يحدث هذا بين مصر
والسودان من جهه واثيوبيا هل يمكن ان تقبل
اثيوبيا بالجلوس الى طاوله حوار مع
السودان ومصر لحلحله هذه الامور
اعتقد لا تقبل بهذا الامر والامر بسيط جدا
وبمعادله بسيطه لاننا لا نحن ولا سعاده
السفير وبلاده
بامريكان ولا كنديين فلماذا يكونون
مرجعيتنا في اتفاقيات لديها جزئيات وجوانب
معينه ربما رؤيتك للحل بين خبراء الدول
الثلاثه الحل ان نتوافق مع الدول بين
الدول الثلاثه واحسان النيه وحسن النوايا
على غرار سعاده السفير دون التطرق الى هذه
الملفات التي يتطرفون من خلالها بهذه
التصريحاتك الرصينه الفكره واضحه السيد
هريدي رؤيتك للحل كيف ترى الحل
رؤيتي للحل يا فندم حاليا حضرتك الحكومه
الاثيوبيه تتقدم بمشروع اتفاق هي اللي
تقوم تتقدم بمشروع اتفاق من خلال الرئاسه
رئاسه جزر القمر للاتحاد الافريقي تقدم
بمشروع اتفاق ويتم مناقشته والتفاوت حوله
بين الحكومات الاثيوبيه والمصريه
والاثيوبيه اما ان احنا نستمر على تكرار
هذه المواقف ان احنا نريد الحل في اطار
الاتحاد الافريقي نحن نعارد التدوين الذي
تقوم به به مصر كل هذا الكلام لا يؤدي الى
شيء نحن في انتظار في انتظار خطوه ايجابيه
من جانب الحكومه الاثيوبيه حول هذا
الموضوع شكرا لك السفير حسين هريدي مساعد
وزير خارجيه المصريه السابق كنت معنا من
القاهره وشكرا لضيفنا من اديس ابا محمد
العروسي النائب في البرلماني الفيدرالي
الاثيوبي شكرا لكما وبهذا ناتي الى ختام
هذه الحلقه
[موسيقى]